We just got home from vacation,
and while unpacking, I realized that we didn't have any deodorant.
When I mentioned that to lucky,
he said he was gonna make some really quick.
Started by combining all the ingredients that needed to melt together,
which was some beeswax, few tablespoons of coconut oil,
and then some cocoa butter.
After all the ingredients were combined in the bowl,
we moved over to heating them up on the stove until they were melted.
While those were melting, he combined all of the dry ingredients,
which were some baking soda,
aero root powder, and since he's a baker,
he needs everything leveled and very precise.
He combined those two things in a bowl
and then realized that he needed a bigger bowl.
At this point,
he poured all the melted ingredients into the dry ingredients,
making sure to mix it really well until it formed a paste.
Once it came together, he scooped it into two different bowls.
Since he was making two different scents,
one for me and one for him.
I wanted a lavender scent,
and he went with a eucalyptus scent.
Once all of that was combined,
he scooped it into these little glass jars,
making sure to clean up the rim before closing them up ready to use.